Everything on the surface of life changes.
Everything you can perceive and sense changes
in some way, at some point.
This may sound dismal, but it is not.
Change is not something to be afraid of.
It is something that provides excitement,
progression, and a sense of life.
What’s ironic about change is how much we
appear to hate and resist it, despite how
inevitably rooted and essential it is to life.
We are all afraid of the uncertainty that
comes with change.
We are all afraid of leaving this moment and
stepping into the next.
Even if this moment is not so great, it is
often still better than the idea of what can
change in the next.
We would rather things be not so great, than
go through the risk and process of change.
But regardless of our fear and resistance
to change, it is inevitable.
We must overcome our fear of it and embrace
it in our lives so that we can experience
its opportunity, progression, and excitement.
Like overcoming any type of fear, one must
face change and understand it in order to
come to terms with it.
What’s interesting about change is how we
only really care to notice it when it is sudden,
unforeseen, and dramatic.
Rather, when it is gradual, we barely notice
or care about it.
We assimilate it into life and enjoy the sense
of forward motion that it brings to us.
But what we must understand is that sometimes
change occurs underneath the surface, and
we don’t see the gradual progression.
But this change is no different.
It is not something to be more fearful or
resistant to.
The only difference is how we perceive and
experience the suddenness of it.
Consider a friend or a co-worker that you
see every couple of days.
Let’s imagine they are growing their hair
out from a very short length to a very long
length.
You see them multiple times every week so
you do not notice their hair grow because
the amount each week is exceptionally minute
and unnoticeable to the naked eye.
You don’t care about or react to this change
and you easily accept the longer hair.
Now imagine an old friend or family member
whom you don’t see too often.
This person is also growing their hair out
from a short length to a long length.
The last time you saw this person, their hair
was very short.
Now after a long period of time, you are seeing
them and their hair is significantly longer.
When you see them, the new change is jarring
and you likely have a difficult time accepting
it right away.
Life changes and grows like hair; millimeter-by-millimeter.
But when we only see the change in centimeters
or meters, it shocks us and we resist it.
We accuse people, systems, and ideas of being
fake, disingenuous, or impractical.
Although there are cases where this may be
true, it is important that we do not jump
to such conclusions as a result of our fear
of change.
We must understand that change is always happening
and just because it appears sudden to us,
does not make it negative.
Life is in constant flux, and by resisting
change, we are resisting life.
We must stop and consider change’s essence
to life and not let fear get in the way of
embracing
and enjoying it.